[Musique]
les plus hautes personnalités de la
république française ont salué à
l'elysée l'impératrice et le shah d'iran
hôte du général et de madame de gaulle
vous est pour la france un ami avait dit
le chef de l'état français en
accueillant le matin même le souverain
d'iran en l'honneur des invités de la
france il donnait au soir de cette
première journée un grand dîner 298
pouvait
oh
[Musique]
mais paris réservé à l'impératrice farah
qui était il n'y a pas si longtemps
simplement l'étudiante farah diba un
autre rendez vous celui de la mode elle
a pu admirer avec la princesse chanas
fille du che à une sélection des
créations de 22 grands couturiers
parisiens
une quintessence de la motte
[Musique]
la rentrée universitaire est commencé
pour loger les effectifs estudiantins
268 mille élèves de l'enseignement
supérieur deux cent mille mètres carrés
de locaux nouveaux ont été construits et
5000 étudiants trouveront place dans les
nouveaux bâtiments de la faculté des
sciences édifié au dessus de la vieille
halle aux vins
[Musique]
de conception très moderne doté de
salles de travaux nombreuses et de
laboratoires parfaitement outillé ses
huit amphithéâtres spacieux lui
permettre de décongestionner les anciens
établissements d agrandissement prévu
lui permettront d'accueillir dix neuf
mille étudiants un bel effort et qui
doivent poursuivre
formose célébré avec éclat sous la
présidence de chiang kai shek le 50e
anniversaire de la révolution qui me
fait en 1911 au règne de la dynastie
mandchoue et en un temps à 4000 ans de
régime monarchique en chine un défilé
militaire à marquer à taipei cette
commémoration onze mille hommes de
toutes les armes les fusées
antiaériennes des organisations
paramilitaires féminine participaient à
cette manifestation en même temps que
1000 véhicules et près de 200 avions à
réaction
cette commémoration était placée sous le
signe du double 10 qui représente le 10
octobre date de la naissance de sun yat
sen fondateur de la république chinoise
m
vingt mille hommes en oeuvre sous le
regard du président kennedy cpe sans
doute en comparaison des quatre cent
mille soldats qui manoeuvre sous
pavillon soviétique en allemagne de
l'est
mais ces exercices d'ensemble n'ont été
que le prélude à la gigantesque
opération bouclier du ciel qui devait
mettre en jeu la totalité des forces
aériennes américaines
du côté des russes deux parachutistes
ont accompli une double performance
sauté en chute libre et ce film est
mutuellement
prouesses acrobatiques
oui mais également prouesse technique
avec la réussite d'un parent ait rappelé
[Musique]
tour de force technique sans doute mais
les techniques modernes nous ont
habitués à de semblables tour de force
c'est parce au contexte surtout que
l'immersion d'un oléoduc de 86 cm de
diamètre à travers l'isère mérite d'être
mentionné jusqu'ici en effet le pétrole
qu'ils viennent du moyen-orient ou
d'afrique devait emprunter l'atlantique
pour gagner l'europe du nord
la construction du pipeline sud européen
ouvre désormais au pétrole une route
directe qui court circuite le long
chemin traditionnel des tanks est avec
le pipeline dont la pose se poursuit au
long de la vallée du rhône et qui
reliera marseille ac arles crau le
pétrole brut n'aura plus que 750 km à
parcourir au lieu de 4500 que doivent
couvrir les cargos le pipeline pour un
véhicule et 15 millions de tonnes de
pétrole par an soit la charge de 300
groupes bancaires
face sur mer pendant ce temps voit
pousser les énormes réservoirs du futur
parc de stockage sur 150 hectares
s'élève d'immenses cuves qui pourront en
à gazinet plus d'un million de mètres
cubes soit la capacité de 24 pétrolier
de 50 mille tonnes
la verano port pétrolier de marseille ou
s'alimentait seule jusqu'ici la région
marseillaise se voit de ce fait promu au
rang de grand port pétrolier de l'europe
mais déjà la verra et marseille doivent
compter avec un rival le port italien de
gênes car le pipeline qui se construit
en france à un concurrent le pipeline
auquel l'italie veut faire franchir les
alpes vers cette même allemagne
les premiers éléments du pipeline
italiens ont d'ores et déjà été posée il
n'y aura pas un mais deux pipelines pour
l'europe
et l'ambition de marseille se heurte
aujourd'hui à gênes qui a refait ses
quais et agrandit son port et c'est
ainsi qu'entre les deux ports
méditerranéens comme entre les deux
pipelines la guerre est aujourd'hui
déclaré
elles sont dix
elles sont dix dont l'âge oscille entre
65 et 80 ans yvonne grand-mère de paris
que leur 707 1 707 à elles toutes n'ont
pas fait renoncer aux divertissements du
maquillage et du déguisement aux joueurs
de ce théâtre sans malice qui évoque une
chorale et puis quand on chante n'est ce
pas c'est qu'on a toujours 20 ans
un
exemple il
et
ouais
oui
ça
papoulias
enfin
ça
ja oui
attali 2
[Musique]